there is some encouraging news from
state's copic 19 response director
stay at home 2.0 appears to be working
but it may not be enough
the i-team's vanessa murphy is live with
more on how state officials are trying
to get this virus under control
vanessa
yeah we could be hearing from governor
sislek over the next few days
about additional guidelines and state
health leaders have to try to figure out
a balance right protect
the public health but also the state's
economy
and in a state like nevada which relies
so heavily
on tourism that's a challenge now as you
mentioned
the 14 day positivity rate is 15.8
percent
5 percent is considered too high
hospitalizations in southern nevada are
continuing to increase
there's a strain on health care staffing
licensed
beds and space here's the state's kovit
19 response director talking about
considering a balanced approach
to address this we know we've done
we've done state home orders before or a
stay at home or before and we've seen
the impact on the virus and we've seen
the impact on
the economy that comes from that we've
tried to do a more targeted approach
and we've seen the impacts on both
through that as well
he says since there's a nationwide surge
there's competition for example
to bring in health care workers the
state is asking people with
medical or science backgrounds to
volunteer for the battleborn health
corps
we have a link at eight newsnow dot com
so again
it is likely we will hear from governor
sisilak over the next few days
about additional guidelines but it
appears he and his team are trying to
avoid another shutdown and instead
continuing to take a more targeted
approach reporting live vanessa murphy 8
news now